[Musique]
Je fais la planche française traditionnelle d'
habitude c'est la réciprocité de ma
grand-mère et je fais tout dans cette cuisine
et là je fais que la traditionnelle
demande aussi tous les légumes et la
volaille et le noir et ainsi de suite et aussi le
foie mais c'était quoi cru et  confit
qui était le traditionnel dans ce top
ouais bon ce n'est pas du tout français mais
ils ont nous avons avant ils ont nous
avons juste très peu très très très
peu mais ce n'est pas bien français regardez vous tous
pas beaucoup donc ce que nous avons  en cours de
route, ça va [ __ ] en l'air qui est sur l'oie ou dans
le noir j'ai dit environ 12 ah ouais - mais
plus pour Noël c'est un
modèle de stratégie à Noël pour ajouter de la saveur
sur la table vous savez je vois beaucoup de la
jeune génération  aller pour la nourriture
oui mais pensez-vous que vous pensez par l'
américain par l'américain bien pour les
américains oui peut-être que c'est très bon pour le
sexe oral chez les gens mais pas pour le latin
veut mais je veux dire italien français ou
espagnol par exemple de super parce que
ce n'est pas  tou  ch ni nourriture on travaille plus
sur le fruit bien car le
noir clair de différence
qu'est-ce que je ne vois pas ça nourriture c'est de la nourriture
c'est très pratique
oui c'est ça
mais pas vrai la beauté c'est douloureux chaine oh
peut être un petit peu oui sur le nouveau  jeune
génération mais j'espère que l'
erreur de la cuisine traditionnelle française que nous avons mise
au four et qu'après un an je serai
cuit parce que c'est tellement bon tellement
bon voir ce que les américains peuvent peut-être
refaire de la restauration rapide si ce n'est pour les français je
ne le fais pas '  t crois qu'on s'y prend vraiment maintenant pour
un sont et combien de temps pour une heure environ
oui quinze de oui une heure environ
et maintenant autre chose maintenant ce qui est mélangé
avec de l'épinard et une voix suave très
typée country à emporter et j'ai mis
le tri  de télé et c'est de la sauce blanche
oui c'est bien ça se mange
avec le voile et avec des oeufs et une tranche
de ha ha finir cette sauce blanche et
après et on la met avec mes épinards dans un
plat
[Musique]
alors tu vois très bien
oui c'est la sauce blanche ce qui n'est pas
q  uite fini encore
je ne pense pas non ce n'est pas assez bon
c'est marrant bon de l'oie sur l'
alcool et les pattes et les ailes et
celles là ne sont que des ailes elles sont les
bienvenues et c'est un plat du Sud
Ouest performé donc je reçois  il en quatre morceaux
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'ils sont destinés à être
mangés froids avec Salah nous pouvons le faire chaud
aussi ce voir qui est cuit dans la graisse
et conservé dans la graisse et c'est ainsi
que s'appelle la piqûre du cou
avec de la farce à l'intérieur, c'est un puits très populaire
dans le sud-ouest,
c'est très typique de faire partie de la
maison, donc les gens de cette partie qui n'ont
pas très bien je veux dire dans le métro à
la porte bien sûr, ils ne savent pas que
très bien
bien fait  ça fait beaucoup c'est des
courgettes et de la salade avec de l'ail et personne
c'est mon mon plat donc on fait autre
chose  il vous voulez changer vous
venez rencontrer et w  hite a choisi après ce qui par
exemple est plus le premier plat juste un
rôti de porc rôti ce n'est pas un nom spécial
en français c'est ho de dépôt pire qu'est ce
qu'environ une heure de différence avec le morceau
de viande c'est gros ou pas mais généralement
environ une heure doit être  tres tres bien
cool faites vous quand vous prendrez votre retraite
oh oui dans note differente a paris avec un
tres difficile a partir et je viens
de la campagne monsieur je reviendrai a
la campagne 65 donc la plupart environ 15 et 20
ans encore au boulot faites vous  avoir l'intention un
moment
tu te maries ok non j'en ai un autre je
dois préférer être à la campagne nous avons
beaucoup de temps et ce qui est très différent
de la relation avec les gens a
très différent
tu prends du temps pour tout
rien d'autre oui j'ai été  à Londres pas
dans ses affaires je n'étais pas avec lui a
façonné son nid pendant quatre ans
pourquoi est-ce que j'apprends l'anglais et j'étais
très content mais je suis revenu et j'ai
ouvert tout le monde un restaurant après ça
ou avec une chanson spécialement pour mon
pays quand  C'est non  t pareil quand je fais
ici bien avant on dit toujours que les
dames françaises sont plus élégantes maintenant je
ne pense pas que ça vaille peut-être encore là
je ne sais pas mais c'était très difficile
de faire des vêtements pour les anglais
finalement le goût était très  différent
très très très différent
avez-vous eu une relation intime avec
des femmes anglaises pendant que vous étiez à
Londres pendant des années pendant que vous étiez à
Londres ce que je ne sais pas ce que vous voulez dire
bien sûr j'ai compris que je sortais
très souvent avec l'anglais je  s'est marié
pas avec un anglais un français oui
depuis combien de temps on a pas
d'enfants plein d'enfants
partout attention des français surveillez
votre côté stade les rongeurs
connaissent le stade soudain eh bien de 25 à
3 ans
et fredonnant rajouté 4 5 7 8 je  sais
pas trop ça en a assez fait j'en ai dit
sur ma vie privée
alors voilà on va au marché maintenant c'est un
beau marché tu achètes ces 950
tables dans mon pied pour ce que je fais
ici en cuisine
ok donc je pense  on y va puis-je  vous dire
quelle est votre opinion personnelle à leur sujet eh
bien je pense que c'est une très bonne chose et
je ne pense pas que cela l'arrêtera car
c'est très utile et bien meilleur que
le marché du poulet que vous voyez car vous
ne trouvez pas cela au supermarché
pensez-vous qu'il existera
encore encore 5 10 ans de temps non non non vous
y restez bien disposition en français les
gens n'aimaient pas trop y aller c'est
pas que les anglais de l'américain
ils préfèrent aller au marché font le
faire du shopping donc quand on est encore debout maintenant je suis juste
encore maintenant ok ok
[Musique]